bonjour à toutes et tous sont nés en
direct sur brut en ce dimanche en fin de
journée avec aurélien barrau qui astro
physicien au cnrs et qui aussi
enseignants sont grenoble bonjour à vous
bonjour merci d'être avec nous on va
parler justement de tout ce qui est en
lien avec le réchauffement climatique
que cette fin du monde que vous évoquez
avec ce livre qui est sorti ces derniers
jours le plus grand défi de l'histoire
de l'humanité
ce livre qui est sorti donc disponible
un petit peu partout maintenant je
rappelle pour ceux qui nous regardent
que vous pouvez partager ce direct mais
aussi de poser vos questions on va
essayer d'en prendre dans l'est dans les
commentaires mais j'aimerais d'abord
vous poser cette première question j'ai
lu attentivement votre livre vous
parlais justement avec des propos assez
alarmiste justement de cette fin du
monde il ya un rapport même de l'onu qui
dit que dans si on fait rien d'ici deux
ans ce serait une catastrophe même
existentielle pour notre survie
finalement qu'est-ce qui vous a donné
envie d'écrire ce livre c'était paul
message que voulait penser en fait j'ai
beaucoup hésité à écrire ce livre je
pense que ça va être un appel parmi
beaucoup d'autres qui ne servira
essentiellement à rien je dirais même
que par sa simple existence il contribue
un peu à la pollution dont il a quelque
chose d'intrinsèquement contre-productif
néanmoins je crois quand même que face à
la catastrophe qui s'annonce
rien n'est pire que de ne rien faire
donc il ya quelques mois avec mon amie
l'actrice juliette binoche on avait
lancé une tribune dans le monde et mon
père m'avait dit bon c'est bien beau
d'être alarmiste mais il faudrait quand
même peut-être aussi donné des ébauches
de solutions donc l'idée du livre
c'était évidemment pas de donner des
clés pour sauver l'humanité sauver la
nature sauver les animaux parce que je
ne suis pas compétent pour ça il ya des
écologues qui sont beaucoup plus à même
de répondre en détail
mais c'était de dire peut-être quand
même qu'il ya quelque chose de cohérent
à aller un peu au delà de la mise en
garde et a proposé quelques pistes pour
tenter non pas de sauver le monde je ne
me prends pas pour pour le messie pour
le prophète
mais en tout cas pour tenter quand même
d'aller un tout petit peu plus avant et
de ne pas en rester simplement au cri
d'alarmé il ya beaucoup de chiffres que
j'ai pu lire dans votre lit notamment
qui va tous nous parler à ceux qui nous
regardent la pollution tue trois fois
plus que le sida
c'est vrai qu'on parle beaucoup du sida
parfois moins des conséquences de la
pollution sur notre notre santé ça veut
dire que chaque année à des millions de
personnes qui sont touchées qui meurent
de la pollution qui a une autre
comparaison qui est peut-être plus
parlante encore c'est que en france
durant les quatre dernières années qui
hélas on était pourtant sanglante de ce
point de vue la pollution a tué huit
cent fois plus que le terrorisme alors
évidemment ça n'excuse pas le terrorisme
n'y a aucun doute là dessus mais ça
devrait quand même peut-être nous
inviter à prendre la mesure où plus
exactement la démesure de cette
catastrophe
je pense que si nous étions rationnelle
c'est une gestion cohérente nous
devrions être en état d'urgence
environnementale depuis bien longtemps
et ce n'est manifestement pas le cas
parce que soyons clairs la transition
que moi j'aimerais plutôt appeler une
révolution écologique n'a toujours pas
commencé
donc on est face à un problème de santé
publique qui est absolument majeur sont
des chiffres officiels ce ne sont pas
des élucubrations d'hurluberlus sont
vraiment des chiffres documenté que
d'ailleurs le président de la république
lui même a repris et vous imaginez le
chef de l'état reconnaît qu'il ya
cinquante mille décès par an dus à la
pollution est alors si on avait le
dixième de cela du à n'importe quoi
d'autre on serait tous état
d'effervescence incroyable la presse ne
parlait que de ça on prélève une de tous
les journaux on serait en état d'alarmé
maximum mais là pour une raison
mystérieuse bah oui c'est la pollution
donc finalement c'est un peu comme si
c'était ce que l'on était notre
ontologie qu'ils soient dévoilait et qui
nous menait à notre perte d'une façon
acceptable
moi je ne pense pas que ce soit
acceptable justement est ce que la vie
aujourd'hui elle est en péril
je parle pour soi les animaux mais aussi
les êtres humains nous sommes
aujourd'hui 7 milliards sur terre oui je
crois qu'en effet on m'a reproché on a
toujours reproché de toute façon mais on
aura en particulier reproché
l'utilisation du terme fin du monde donc
je peux être mon expliquer en quelques
mots
parce que moi je suis astrophysiciens
je sais bien que la planète terre que
d'une planète tellurique va continuer de
tourner autour du soleil même si on fait
les pires dégâts possibles donc
évidemment on se sente le monde
la terre a continué d'exister est
probablement la vie va continuer
d'exister en tant que tel mais enfin
c'est quoi ce qu'on appelle le monde le
monde c'est pas un caillou qui flottent
dans l'espace n'est ce pas la beauté le
sens le merveilleux le magic de ce monde
c'est cette incroyable diversité du
vivant c'est ce fragile qui résultent de
plusieurs millions d'années d'évolution
extrêmement subtile avec des
bifurcations avec des interruptions avec
des reprises et qui donne naissance à
ces millions d'espèces qu'on ne devrait
même pas qualifiés par le terme de
biodiversité
on rate tout la magie toute la poésie si
on lit ça c'est juste la beauté de ce
qui donne un sens à notre existence et
ça bien sûr c'est en péril donc on le
sait depuis quelques jours par le
dernier rapport officiel environ un
million d'espèces sont menacées
d'extinction à court terme mais moi ce
que j'aimerais dire c'est que au delà
des espèces il est indispensable de
penser en termes d' individus et si je
vous dis par exemple 6 milliards
d'hommes vont mourir demain
c'est un drame pourtant l'espèce humaine
ne serait pas menacé
donc il faut pas simplement pensé en
termes d'espèces les vivants sont des
individus singuliers et en ce moment ce
qu'on observe c'est que les populations
animales sont en train de s'effondrer
même au sein des espèces qui ne sont pas
menacés et donc pour répondre à votre
question en un beau oui la vie sur terre
aujourd'hui est en train de péricliter
et là je crois qu'on peut tous être
d'accord pour convenir de ce qu'il
s'agit vraisemblablement d'une des plus
grandes catastrophes de l'histoire parce
que pour un vivant la vie ça peut quand
même pas tout à fait être un détail on
parle du réchauffement climatique mais
mais aussi de l'espace pour les animaux
sauvages on sait que il ya 60% des
animaux sauvages ont disparu sur ces
dernières décennies
ils ont pu l'espace pour vivre
aujourd'hui c'est ça aussi l'un des
constats à côté de ce réchauffement
climatique oui je pense que c'est très
important
en parler parce que on se focalise sur
le réchauffement climatique leur des
gens je veux tu lis pas assez sur le
réchauffement climatique quand on voit
l'importance qu'on donne dans certains
médias ou faits divers j'aimerais qu'on
en parle plus mais par rapport au grand
problème qui est celui de notre avenir
commun
le réchauffement climatique nous
n'oublions pas les qu'un élément parmi
d'autres
et en effet je crois qu'il est tout à
fait essentiel qu on parle d autre
élément catastrophique parce que
j'aimerais insister sur le fait que le
constat que nous venons d'établir à
savoir le fait que dans les 40 dernières
années 60% des animaux sauvages ont
disparu
c'est pas une crainte là on n'est pas en
train de parler de notre de notre
anxiété on est en train de parler d'un
bilan quelque chose qui a eu lieu est
bien dans cet état de fait le
réchauffement climatique n'a
pratiquement joué aucun rôle
ce que je suis en train de dire c'est
que quand bien même la température ne
célébrait pas d'un seul degré nous
aurions quand même dans une situation
catastrophique et la raison de sa la
première raison de sa c'est
effectivement l'expansionnisme humain
nous avons transformé la terre en un
vaste parking de supermarché et les
vivants non humains avec lesquels nous
sommes en symbiose un évidemment ils ont
une valeur en tant que tel et ils ont
une nécessité pour notre propre
existence
et bien c'est vivant non simplement plus
de place pour vivre en france
rien qu'en france l'artificialisation
des terres fait qu'on perd environ un
département français tous les dix ans
c'est monstrueux à l'échelle mondiale
la superficie des villes augmente de 4
soupçon riolo mètre carré par an la
taille des forêts diminue de 70 mille
kilomètres carrés par an on est en train
d'envahir l'espace un rythme et dans une
démesure qui fait qu'effectivement
n'ayant plus de place il meurt il ya une
citation qui est intéressant dans votre
livre vous parlez fusion du comportement
de l'homme je vais vous citer ballet du
fast décomplexer la richesse obscène
l'égocentrisme prédateurs la figure du
mal possédant firent de son insouciance
sont immensément ringard aujourd'hui il
est temps de faire savoir le ridicule de
ces postures et de valoriser une
certaine humilité responsable c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui nos comportements
notre vision de la société elle et elle
est incompatible justement etc ce qui
est en train de se passer sur le
le climat a en fait on y réfléchissant
souvent on dit qu'on a tout pour elle
n'est ce pas il ya les petits gestes
individuels
je pense que c'est très bien il faut
absolument le faire c'est tout à fait
évident que ça ne suffit pas et puis à
l'autre à l'autre extrême il ya l'action
politique c'est à dire les décideurs
prennent des mesures que nous subissons
et ça aussi je pense qu'il faut le faire
mais je trouve que ça ne suffit pas non
plus et entre les deux j'ai quand même
l'impression qu'il ya un registre sur
lequel on peut agir et qui a une
importance considérable c'est le
registre symbolique
moi j'aime à dire que nous sommes au mot
symbolique us c'est à dire que nous
sommes des êtres de symbole une très
grande partie je crois un de nos actions
sont en réalité commandes et dirigé
induite par le regard qu'elle déclenche
dans l'autre qui nous observent qui nous
admirent ou au contraire qui nous
répondre
et jusqu'à maintenant le fait est que
les comportements très prédateurs envers
la nature envers les animaux et envers
nos semblables ont été plutôt valoriser
la quelqu'un pour le dire de façon
caricaturale qui se comporte vraiment
comme un mâle dominant et quand même un
peu de frais une figure patriarcale
aussi dans tout ça est plutôt
positivement connoté les choses sont en
train de changer et je pense que ce
changement va nous aider parce que en
effet il ya un certain esthétisme
c'est à dire un respect plus qu une
prédation c'est à dire une osmose plus
qu'une domination qui pourrait prévaloir
et qui changerait les comportements
parce que dès lors que posséder une
voiture de sport un yacht ou rêvé
d'aller passer ses vacances à saint
barth sera considéré comme ringard et je
crois qu'il faut le faire
plus personne n'aura envie de le faire
et donc on n'aura même pas besoin de
passer par la loi
et ça je crois qu'on a tout à y gagner
d'abord parce que les gens qui ont moins
d'argent pourront à nouveau disposer
d'une plus grande dignité
ce qui me semble évidemment souhaitable
et puis ensuite bien sûr parce que ça
aura des effets très bénéfiques sur
l'environnement sur la nature sur le
climat la biodiversité
tu es sur tout ce qui nous importe
injuste oui cette question qui se pose
c'est est ce qu'on peut réussir à
concilier écologie et capitalisme
je ne sais pas moi quand je m'intéresse
à cette question de l'écologie
je le remarque que la principale la
principale le principal reproche qu'on
faisait souvent hélas oui mais attention
vous n'avez pas clairement identifié les
causes et tant que vous ne vous attaquez
pas aux causes
il va rien se passer le problème c'est
que personne n'est d'accord pour les
causes
certains y voient le capitalisme
d'autres y voient le néolibéralisme ce
qui n'est pas exactement la même chose
d'autres y voient pour des raisons moins
étrange mais je pourrais expliquer la
religion etc
donc chacun à son analyse sur l'origine
du problème et chacun croit que tant
qu'on n'aura pas traiter cette origine
alors rien n'aura de sens l'ennui c'est
qu'on ne s'accordera jamais sur
l'origine donc moi je crois qu'il faut
commencer par traiter le problème en lui
même et on verra bien dans une sorte
d'inversion de sens
quel est le système qui permet de le
faire si vous me demandez mon avis
personnel je crois en effet que le
capitalisme débridé
je crois que cette religion la
croissance qui est totalement
irrationnelle autant du point de vue
éthique du point de vue scientifique que
du point de vue écologique et cetera ne
peut pas être conciliable avec un
respect du vivant et un avenir durable
voilà on le sert une croissance
exponentielle dans un monde fini n'est
pas éternellement possible et là je
crois quand même qu'il faut que le
sérieux change de camp ce ne sont pas
les apôtres de la croissance ces gens
sérieux même s'ils sont bien habillés en
costume cravate ce ne sont pas eux ce
sont les écologistes certains jeux pas
sérieux non plus d'ailleurs mais ce sont
les bons écologistes qui nous explique
que la croissance si vous voulez il ya
une remarque très simple qu'on peut
faire c'est que bien sûr ça a marché
c'est tout à fait vrai que ça élever le
niveau de vie
jean que ça endiguer la pauvreté qui a
permis développement de l'hygiène dans
la médecine
tout cela est tout à fait correct mais
maintenant ça s'inverse et c'est un peu
comme de manger quand vous êtes dans un
état de famine ou d'état même normal
d'ailleurs c'est très bien de manger et
même de bien manger mais quand vous êtes
jobez ça vous tue et actuellement on est
entré un régime d'obésité et par
conséquent pour suivre la croissance
c'est intrinsèquement mortifère
mais ça c'est pas du tout du mysticisme
c'est l'analyse rationnelle la plus
triviale la plus évidente et la plus
élémentaire
c'est à dire quelque part que dans le
dollar par les jugements du capitalisme
là on parle de la croissance aussi
chaque année où chaque pays va avoir une
croissance importante
est-ce qu'il faut ne pas avoir le tabou
de dire est ce qu'on veut partir dans
une forme de décroissance
ça c'est vous avez raison c'est
incroyable pas quand j'emploie le mot
décroissance dans une émission de télé
ou de radio on interrompt décroissance
vous voulez dire que vous êtes des
croissants d'un seul coup c'est comme si
on passait du mauvais côté mais avant on
était l'astrophysicien écolo un peu
sympa bienvenu bien d'un seul coup on se
dit oh là là mais peut-être qu'il est
dangereux en fait peut-être qui fait
partie de la secte des décroissants
c'est complètement ubuesque
je veux dire bien sûr il faut décroître
c'est une évidence
on est actuellement en train de
consommer plusieurs fois les ressources
de la terre chaque année s'ils ont des
crois pas évidemment qu'on va à la
catastrophe
enfin je veux dire c'est vous avez un
bocal vous le remplissez de billes
quelqu'un vous dit attention au bout
d'un moment ça va déborder et quelqu'un
d'autre vous dis non non on peut
continuer éternellement qui est sérieux
votre avis c'est une évidence mais ce
que je voudrais souligner c'est que le
mot décroissance il est mal choisi parce
qu'il est tributaire des indicateurs de
l'ancien monde
moi j'ai envie d'évaluer la croissance
non pas sur le pib mais sur la capacité
à s'entraider sur l'amour sur la beauté
sur le respect de la vie sur le
développement des espèces sur la
pérennité du système sur la diminution
des inégalités de ce point de vue là on
n'est pas du tout une croissance en ce
moment et ce que je propose
moi j'ai pas de programme politique je
ne vais pas entrer en politique mais ce
que nous proposons c'est précisément de
croître par rapport à ces nouveaux
indicateurs que je crois être de
meilleurs indicateurs
vous êtes très nombreux à suivre là il
ya beaucoup de questions et commentaires
de laon
vous salue toutes et tous ceux qui nous
regardent et qui viennent de nous
rejoindre je rappelle que vous pouvez
partager ce direct en bas à gauche poser
vos questions dans les commentaires
et en réaction à un ajustement à vos
propos et aux questions qu'on aborde
actuellement il y en a une qui revient
régulièrement sur la natalité sert qu'on
parle justement de croissance et s'est
déguisé mais voilà on était quelques
milliards il ya encore 50 cent soixante
ans les 7 milliards aujourd'hui il ya
des perspectives qui nous a eu 9 10
milliards dans très peu de temps est ce
qu'il ne faudrait pas baisser le nombre
de natalité est ce que c'est grave
aujourd'hui de voir que le nombre
d'êtres humains ne cesse de croître
d'année en année ça c'est un problème
très compliqué moi je crois qu'il faut
se garder de réponse à l'emporte-pièce
cette question qui est très subtil et
très piégeuse finalement évidemment si
on était très peu nombreux on pourra
vraiment sur une bourse et de façon
totalement débridée sans impacter
massivement notre environnement
mais est-ce que ça serait vraiment un
très joli moule moi je ne crois pas le
problème de la natalité c'est que se
reproduire c'est quelque chose qui est
au coeur du vivant c'est un peu la
raison d'être ou en tous les cas un des
moteurs fondamentales de la vie
donc moi je ne suis pas favorable à des
mesures dictatoriales autoritaire sur la
natalité
néanmoins c'est vrai qu'on peut pas
continuer de croître éternellement on va
pas accroître éternellement on sait que
dans trente ans après ça va se
stabiliser on n'est pas du tout en
croissance exponentielle
mais enfin quand même ça va se
stabiliser une valeur un peu haute donc
moi je serais favorable à ce qu'on tente
effectivement de faire baisser la
population humaine mais par des mesures
autoritaires ça c'est pas possible
surtout dans les pays pauvres ça serait
un geste outrageusement colonialiste que
personnellement je réprouve de façon
très claire et vous savez ce qui fait
baisser la natalité c'est par les
mesures autorités enfin ça peut le faire
et ce n'est pas la bonne manière de le
faire c'est essentiellement l'assurance
chômage et l'assurance maladie
est ce que dans beaucoup de pays les
enfants c'est une assurance sur l'avenir
dès lors qu'il ya des protections
sociales qui permettent de vivre plus
sereinement automatiquement la natalité
baisse est donc là encore vous voyez
qu'on a tout à gagner
on peut prendre des mesures qui sont à
la fois bonnes pour la nature est bonne
pour l'interaction entre les hommes et
justement voulez vous qu'ils ont reculé
vous parlait il ya un terme qui m'a
marqué c'est celui de sérénité sociale
salaire minimum et maximum esquevin peut
nous expliquer en quoi consiste cette
idée de sérénité sociale qui permettrait
d'aller justement dans le sens d'un
monde un meilleur bond à bord c'est
peut-être mes propres convictions et
nous sommes toujours en fait des liens
conscient ou inconscient entre les
causes qu'on défend donc là je peux tout
à fait pleine emma partialité
j'ai aucun problème avec ça mais plus
fondamentalement soyons clair il faut
décroître en termes de pib en termes
d'exploitation des ressources ça j'en
suis absolument convaincu c'est
rationnel n'importe qui réfléchissant un
peu sur la question parviendra à cette
conclusion
mais en même temps il ya beaucoup de
pauvreté dans le monde et même en france
il ya des gens qui dorment dans la rue
donc comment fait on pour concilier
cette nécessité de décroissance matériel
avec évidemment la problématique de ce
qu'on ne veut pas baisser le niveau de
vie de ceux qui ont déjà presque rien de
même le monte au contraire pas pour moi
la solution elle est simple c'est le
partage c'est un peu de mise en commun
autrement dit eu la révolution
écologique qui est nécessaire on s'en
sortira pas avec une évolution toussaint
que ce soit clair la révolution
écologique y est nécessaire elle va
contre notre confort façon globale il va
falloir faire des efforts mais moi je
crois que ces efforts et ne doivent pas
être portés par ceux qui n'ont déjà
presque rien ce serait indécent et en
plus ça se fera pas d'ailleurs donc la
seule façon peut-être de ré enchanter un
peu les choses
elie parvenir en fait c'est à dire
trophy ton de la contrainte écologique
pour en plus mettre en place une
évolution sociale qui soit sereine et
qui sont un peu raisonnable enfin
aujourd'hui on a vu qu'il ya quelques
dizaines de personnes qui possèdent
autant que la moitié de l'humanité qui
peut décemment reconnaître que cette
situation est enviable
profitons-en pour non pas faire une
révolution bolchevique c'est pas ce dont
il est question
il est simplement question d'un peu de
raisons de naissance et finalement amour
voilà
du coup je peins de on évoquait
justement cette cette sérénité sociale
ce côté social en ce moment on le voit
dans le pays il ya deux mouvements on
allait les jeunes qui marchent plan
climat on a aussi le mouvement d'aidé
gilet jaune qui est née justement de
cette idée de taxer les carburants
finalement comment on arrive à concilier
fin du monde et fin du mois transition
écologique sans que c'est sans que cela
n'ait aussi une une incidence énorme sur
le portefeuille des plus modestes ou des
classes moyennes oui et c'est vraiment
un problème un soyons bien clairs moi je
ne suis pas candidat aux élections
européennes
donc j'appelle un vrai zombie ancien
joueur de même pour ceux qui n'ont rien
voilà donc moi j'ai pas un programme clé
en main si on est lucide il n'y a pas de
solution simple il n'ya peut-être même
pas de solution du tout il faut juste
oser le reconnaître faut surtout pas
qu'on ait l'impression qu'on est sur la
bonne voie peut-être je le rappelle en
passant les émissions de co2 mondiales
ne font que augmenter les espaces de vie
diminue enfin tous les indicateurs le
transport aérien explose la consommation
de viande en france a repris à la hausse
en fin tous les indicateurs sont mauvais
donc des lions surtout pas l'impression
qu'on est dans la bonne direction il
faut juste faire un petit effort de plus
vives dont on n'a pas commencé
aller dans la bonne direction ce qu'il
faudrait faire une révolution
cette révolution ira contre notre
confort contre notre pouvoir d'achat
bon qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ça moi je
pense que l'analyse rationnelle c'est
que donc elle n'aura pas lieu cette
révolution parce qu'en effet on n'a
jamais vu un peuple se révolter contre
son intérêt à court terme ça ne s'est
jamais produit et c'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire
donc je pense qu'actuellement que ça ne
va pas avoir lieu et qu'on va aller tout
droit vers la pire version du désastre
si on voulait que ça ait lieu quand même
qu'est ce qu'il faudra faire bien voir
qu'on soit un peu raisonnable
c'est-à-dire qu'en effet il faudrait que
les plus aisés prennent sur eux les
évolutions drastique qui sont
nécessaires parce que si on se contente
de commenter les taxes sur le carburant
ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que les riches continueront
à utiliser leur voiture exactement la
même manière et que les pauvres ne
pourront plus le faire ça c'est
évidemment pas acceptable
donc on n'a pas d'autre moyen d'espérer
que de tenter de faire
l'évolution sociale en même temps que la
révolution écologique mais je ne vois
aucun indicateur aujourd'hui qui nous
laisse espérer que ça va avoir lieu ou
pas justement j'ai découvert il ya
quelques semaines cette action de la
république des pôles heures à la défense
où il ya plusieurs sociétés qui ont été
ciblés notamment total la société
générale c'est de se dire que finalement
on parle justement de cette idée pouvoir
d'achat entre les plus pauvres les
classes moyennes et ceux qui ont
justement si vous en trouvez c'est vers
eux qu'il faudrait se diriger pour fois
les taxes et plus pourraient créer une
taxe spéciale sanctionner les mauvais
comportements plus lorsque ces agences
est absolument convaincu là il ya un
levier politique qui est indispensable
la politique fiscale c'est ce qu'on a
tous fait s'il n'a finalement au niveau
politique le moyen d'action tout
efficace plus rapide le plus facile
c'est la politique fiscale
donc évidemment il faut le faire mais en
même temps il faut pas se dédouaner pour
autant parce que si les entreprises les
plus prédatrice existe c'est aussi parce
qu'on achète leurs produits donc il faut
être un peu subtil on peut pas faire
reposer toute la responsabilité sur
l'individu parce qu'il y a un problème
systémique
ça c'est essentiel on peut pas
simplement se dire on va sauver le monde
avec des beauty geste sympathique en
achetant bio équitable et puis on sait
en plus que beaucoup de gens n'ont pas
les moyens de le faire donc on peut pas
simplement dire c'est la responsabilité
individuelle ne peut pas non plus
simplement dire c'est un problème
d'entreprise ou telle entreprise c'est
pas des entités biologiques autonomes
elles sont faites par des gens dont les
entreprises c'est nous les entreprises
elles vivent parce qu'on achète leurs
produits et bien sûr elles reproduisent
nos attentes
donc tout ça est imbriqué le levier
fiscal existe mais il peut pas être
complètement déconnecté d'un
environnement global qui fait qu'il faut
juste renoncer un certain rapport au
monde qui est un rapport dans lequel
l'hubris c'est-à-dire l'excès
technologique a pris le pas sur des
valeurs fondamentales évidente de
rapport au vivant que nous avons perdus
si ton tel que nous
effectivement jamais possédé l'embarras
et qui gestes au quotidien que chacun
peut faire à son échelle mais justement
j'ai lu parce que vous avez a listé dans
votre livre
et ça rebondit peut-être un peu sur vos
propos vous évoquez un moment donné le
fait de faire moins d'achats sur des
sites aux pratiques peu responsables
qu'est ce que vous leur reprochez et
qu'est ce que chacun peut faire
justement là-dessus
oui madame que plus responsable tout est
dans le beau mais enfin on sait quand
même qu'il ya des très très grosse
entreprise extraordinaire mon riches qui
ne paient pratiquement pas d'impôts par
exemple qui tue le commerce de proximité
qui ont non seulement un comportement
qui socialement irresponsable avec leurs
employés et qui est écologiquement
dramatique parce qu'elle favorise
beaucoup de transport de colis et
d'acheminement de colis parfois par voie
aérienne et c est ce genre de chansons
parfois respecter les contraintes les
plus élémentaires ou le bon sens le plus
élémentaire ça moi je crois que dans la
mesure du possible il faut arrêter
j'insiste sur le dans la mesure du
possible parce qu'il ya toujours des
contre exemples on va me rétorquer que
untel ou untel eux habitent à 50 km de
la première librairie que donc il n'a
pas le choix mais mais bien sûr il y a
toujours de bons contres exemples mais
enfin je dirais qu de façon tendancielle
on s'est quand même ce qu'il faudrait
faire pour relocaliser un peu l'économie
et pourrait effectivement faire les
efforts parce que ça demande des efforts
il faut arrêter de se mentir comme
dirait mon ami grandsir il faut arrêter
de se mentir
d'accord on peut pas gagner sur tous les
tableaux l'idée qu'on va pouvoir
continuer à voir de plus en plus de
smartphones hyperperformants
d'ordinateurs partout dans le
gigantesque écran lcd partout chez nous
et en même temps voir les insectes les
oiseaux et les baleines survivre c'est
fou on peut pas gagner partout donc la
question à se poser c'est est ce que
dans 50 ans on a envie que nos
descendants est la dix septième
génération de téléphones portables qui
sera tellement rapide qu'on pourra
télécharger tout internet en cas de
seconde ou est ce qu'on a envie que la
vie
c'est encore autour de nous et que cette
extraordinaire construction perdure un
peu moi je crois que quand on en sera là
17 g on se dira que quand même les
baleines les retours et les mantes
religieuses
c'était peut-être un peu mieux et ça
sera trop tard justement ça me fait
revenir sur une question celle des lois
qui pourrait nous restreindre au
quotidien on sait que c'est pas évident
voilà d'aller sur sur ce terrain là qui
serait on va dire plutôt arrêter le
sévérité individuel c'est ce que vous
dites qu'ils sont incompatibles avec la
vie commune
comment voilà qu'ally ce qu'est ce qu'il
faudra limiter présence quelques quelle
mesure concrètement il faudrait prendre
aujourd'hui mesures contraignant donc du
coût qui sera peut-être un populaire
d'un côté mais qui serait pour vous on
va dire urgente
bon je sais pas je laisse aux politiques
de décider mais enfin par exemple des
gens qui ont les moyens ça concerne pas
tout le monde et qui vont passer toutes
leurs vacances le bout du monde
aujourd'hui c'est juste un insensé le
tourisme a un effet dramatique par
exemple dans l'environnement c'est un
exemple parmi mille autres
mais ce qui est important dans cette
question c'est de savoir s'il ya eu
dérive si un risque
vous savez moi j'ai beaucoup entendu
parler de dictature verte de stalinisme
écologique etc
personne ne veut ça que ce soit bien
clair mais moi je pense que c'est
indécent aujourd'hui d'oser parler de ça
écoutez imaginer un prisonnier de guerre
qui est humilié qui est maltraité qui
est torturé on essaye de me donner
quelques droits est ce qu'on est en
train d'en faire un dictateur enfin
soyons sérieux c'est ça aujourd'hui qui
se passe la nature aujourd'hui être
humiliée elle est tellement maltraitée
qu'elle est en train de mourir
on essaye de vous donner quelques droits
on n'est pas en train d'en faire une
dictature
on est en train d'essayer de sauver un
corps mourant sauf que ce corps ce sont
des milliards de milliards d'individus
et des millions d'espèces
je pense que ça n'aurait rien de
scandaleux voilà nous sommes en ce
moment
trois tgv heureusement car beaucoup de
lois enfin il faut pas faire comme s'il
a aujourd'hui on est dans la liberté
totale
heureusement que non si vous m'aviez
c'est là tout de suite j'ai pas droite
et réciproquement et tant mieux la loi
nous protège elle nous met quand même à
l'abri d'un certain nombre de prédation
de folie que de comportements agressifs
pourquoi at on le droit de détruire la
vie alors qu'on n'a pas le droit par
exemple de porter atteinte à une
entreprise on n'a pas le droit de casser
la vitrine d'un d'un vendeur de ce plat
tout prêt prédateurs tant mieux je ne
dis pas qu'il faut avoir le droit de le
faire
c'est interdit donc la loi protège des
entreprises prédatrices
mais la loi ne protège pas la vie sur
terre moi je pense que l'infime perte de
liberté qui en résulteraient peut-être
mais ce qu'on n'aurait plus le droit de
faire certaines choses
in fine et j'aurai dans le sens de la
liberté parce que si on fait rien dans
trente ans on pourra plus sortir de chez
nous avec des tétines des canicules à
55° ça c'est une part de liberté
fondamentale on pourra plus sortir de
chez nous vous savez que le corps humain
lorsque la température est supérieure à
la température interne quand on est au
delà 37° fonctionne très mal et on sait
maintenant on aura des épisodes
caniculaires l'on est ce que vous croyez
quand même pas qu'une petite privation
de liberté qui nous j'empêcherai d'avoir
des comportements ultra prédateurs et
mitraillent waste puisqu'il emmène tout
le monde tous les livres ont tous plus
magnifiques dans cette chute que
endiguer ces comportements là serait une
perte de liberté beaucoup moins grand
que la perte de liberté qui va survenir
avec finalement la mort à la mort de
tout le monde par la mort de toute la
vie et un soyons sérieux
mais enfin le spectre de la mort qui est
déjà en train d'impacter aujourd'hui la
vie sur terre
vraiment j'insiste parce que je me rends
compte que beaucoup de gens pour son
corps que c'est la crainte d'un futur
improbable
j'insiste c'est un bilan on a perdu 60%
des animaux sauvages en 40 ans s'est
fait ça a lieu c'est pas simplement une
peur et sur la perspective justement des
prochaines années les prochaines
décennies aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya des
choses qu'on peut d'ores et déjà
annoncer si rien ne change
ah oui alors c'est rien ne change par
exemple on parle de plus de 5 degrés
c'est pas du tout car si rien ne change
on est plutôt à +5 de drake vient sinon
c'est quoi
plus simple de 5
plus la bhl c'est incalculable lorsque
le système planétaire alors là l'europe
en quelques secondes la casquette de
physiciens et soumis à des rétroactions
positives des rétroactions positives ça
veut dire qu'elle est effet
d'emballement
ça veut dire qu'il ya des paliers quand
on passe certains paliers au lieu que le
système relax c'est à dire retourne
spontanément vers un état d'équilibré
en fait ils s'emballent et le conduit de
diverger vers un état hors équilibre
on est en train de passer ces paliers
avec des règlements de ce niveau avec le
permafrost par exemple qui va fondre qui
va libérer méthane qui est un gaz à
effet de serre beaucoup plus dangereux
plus efficace que le dioxyde de carbone
on va avoir des effets d'emballement qui
sont telles que tout ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que ce sera pire que ce qu'on peut
prévoir à l'heure actuelle donc c'est
effectivement terrifiant alors vous vous
savez que quand je dis que c'est
terrifiant certains me reprochent de
déprimer la jeunesse c'est quand même
extraordinaire comme si dire la vérité
vous faisait porter le chapeau de la
culpabilité et en plus la jeunesse je
crois que ceux qui la terrifie
c'est pas qu'on lui dise la vérité c'est
qu'elle voit l'inaction des responsables
alors une incidence aussi où vous donner
justement quelques pistes ou même des
évolutions qu'il y aurait dans les
prochaines années sur le sur le climat
mais l'incidence pour les êtres humains
on parle beaucoup justement des lieux
qui serait qu'ils sont habités
maintenant et qui serait inévitable une
migration importante est ce qu'on a des
chiffres de personnes qui pourraient
être amenés à migrer des conséquences
que cela pourrait avoir sur notre monde
sur la planète qu'effectivement bon le
l'onu qui connaît l'une des instances un
peu respectables tant de sites de
chiffrer ces déplacements de population
c'est très difficile de le faire avec
une précision donc les marges d'erreur
sont très grandes
mais on peut évaluer dans trente ans des
migrations de l'ordre de 100 millions à
un milliard de personnes
trente ans c'est bientôt on parle plus
de nos arrière-petits-enfants ni même de
nos petit enfants ni même de nos enfants
dans trente ans si tout se passe bien
vous et moi on sera encore vivant donc
ce sont des choses qu'on va connaître
écoutez quand on voit la manière dont
l'europe s'est comporté un guillemant
face à la crise des rires
j ai syrien que nous avons en grande
partie laissait mourir devant de
frontières close alors qu'il s'agissait
d'un ou deux millions personnes
comment pensez vous que nous allons
gérer 500 millions de personnes voyez
que les frontières s'ouvriront venez
chez nous venez je vous en prie ici
c'est plus tempéré que vous êtes
bienvenus évidemment non hélas ce sera
la guerre
et là encore soyons bien clairs c'est
pas une prédiction apocalyptique
millénariste moi je suis pas un vendeur
de peur j'ai rien à gagner dans cette
affaire c'est une analyse rationnelle
factuel si on analyse à partir des
données historiques c'est ce qui va se
passer
donc là évidemment on voit que
l'humanité est directement touchée et au
delà de l'humanité que la vie est
directement touché qu'est ce que vous
répondez ajustements aux
climato-sceptiques justement vous
directement ou lisent et voilà on n'est
pas là pour faire peur on n'est pas là
aujourd'hui on entend encore parfois on
a même vu à la télévision et quelques
jours certains discours qui veulent
minimiser ou en tout cas
alors écoutez moi je crois que je vais
changer de stratégie il ya quelques
années des climato-sceptiques fallait
aller combattre
aujourd'hui il faut les ignorer ce sont
au mieux des rigolos au pire des
criminels
j'ai rien à dire à ces gens là vous
évoquez un terme qui revient
régulièrement réalisés dans cette
interview même si dans votre livre le
terme de révolution
je vous cite plusieurs évolutions
fondamentales sont sans doute à
effectuer à l'occasion de cette urgence
écologique
quelles sont-elles exactement s'il ya
des pistes à donner concrètement oui
alors soyons bref claire et exhaustif
notre évolution politique d'accords cas
des petites choses qui sont pas mal ya
le pacte mondial pour l'environnement
qui se met en place soit c'est très bien
avec ses des petites choses la
révolution je crois c'est vraiment de
redéfinir nos attentes nous extraire de
la religion de la croissance
mauvaise religion et spiritualité est
tous très belle peut-être qu'il faudra
d'ailleurs même réinventer aujourd'hui
une certaine sacralité ça c'est une
mauvaise relier ensuite au niveau
économique
là aussi il ya des choses très bien dans
les petites choses le pacte le pacte
climat environnement climat je ne suis
plus le nom exact ce truc de la rupture
ou là c'est très bien mais c'est une
petite chose à plus long terme il faut
effectivement redéfinir une politique du
partage et une extraction de cette
fascination pour l'accumulation de la
richesse et pour la fructification de
l'excellent au niveau symbolique on l'a
déjà dit je crois qu'il faut revoir ce
qui est aujourd'hui un regard mélioratif
et un regard péjoratif en valorisant les
comportements raisonnable
tendanciellement acétique et je dirais
respectueux de la vie humaine et animale
au niveau philosophique
il faut nous extraire de cette binarité
à la fois théologique et métaphysique
qui fait que nous sommes crus extérieurs
à la nature mais non la nature ce n'est
pas une ressource la nature c'est nous
nous sommes une partie d'elle ça il faut
vraiment recommencer à le comprendre
et puis je dirais qu'au niveau politique
en quelque sorte
il faut réinventer un langage parce que
nous sommes toujours prisonniers des
limites de nos concepts et je crois que
tout est à réinventer aujourd'hui et ça
c'est vraiment la petite partie
jubilatoire vous avez nous sommes la
génération qui va véritablement flinguer
l'avenir ou au contraire celle qui va
totalement redessiné les pourtours du
réel ça c'est presque un peu excitant et
moi je suis pas très optimiste quand
même mais là il ya quand même lueur
d'espoir on peut tout repenser et ça
peut être pour le meilleur vous évoquez
ses idées d'un point de vue collectif
ont eu du monde
un pauvre la division dans l'événement
tout à l'heure avec les sites aux
pratiques peu responsables que vous
dénoncez mais quelques petits gestes on
peut faire au quotidien pour le plus
générale je parle pour moi pour vous
pour tous ceux qui nous regardent
actuellement sur cela qu'ils veulent ce
qui se dit bon voilà moi je suis touché
par ces questions là mais en même temps
peut-être je fais des choses dans mon
quotidien mais ce qu'il n'ya peut-être
pas des choses à faire en plus qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire en plus pour respecter
plus notre environnement est limité
ce que vous évoquez depuis tout à
l'heure alors là je crois qu'il faut
être clair bon les petits gestes il faut
vraiment le dire elle martelé ne
suffisent pas on ne sauvera pas le monde
ça mais en moins ne pas les faire c'est
quand même ce qu'il ya de pire parce que
c'est chaud mais dans une posture de
dire jouissent selon une dernière fois
c'est trop tard dont jouit son encore
maxime allemand ça c'est complètement
idiot d'ailleurs un parce que c'est trop
tard pour éviter des catastrophes mais
sait jamais trop tard pour éviter que ce
soit encore pire
donc je suis favorable aux petits gestes
lors qu'elles sont il ya tout ce qu'on
sait tous ce qui est évident de
recyclage quand on a les moyens
d'utiliser du bio etc
tout ça est bien connu mais moi je pense
que les petits gestes les plus
fondamentaux c'est quand même de freiner
la consommation c'est-à-dire de réparer
plus que de remplacer
et là je veux être bien clair je suis
pas un donneur de leçons moi même je
suis je possède un téléphone portable
récent donc c'est très dur de résister à
ça parce que la tentation est énorme et
parce qu'on se laisse très vite
convaincre que quand même quand même cet
ordinateur dès leur génération si on en
a les moyens
nous on fera un bon usage bon ça faut
arrêter ça voilà le petit geste le plus
essentiel c'est pas d'acheter équitable
c'est de ne pas acheter c'est d'aller
quand même tendanciellement vers
l'ascétisme moi je me suis séparée de la
voiture j'ai une voiture de sport
d'ailleurs vraiment jeu j'ai vraiment
pas de leçon à donner
bon maintenant je suis pas passé la
voiture électrique j'ai juste dans une
voiture voilà plus de voitures bon on va
dire certains ne peuvent pas le faire
très bien parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas le
faire ne le font pas mais quand on le
peut on essaye de ne pas le faire moi je
les fais un délai à des conférences
presque à l'autre bout du monde pour
parler 20 minutes devant des
spécialistes
ça ça n'a plus de sens il faut
absolument arrêter là encore tout le
monde n'est pas concerné certains n'ont
pas les moyens mais se font pas de
moyens sont pas les plus gros pollueurs
donc c'est pas à eux qu'il faut demander
les plus gros efforts mais c'est quand
même faire des enfants
pour moi c'est un droit auquel je veux
pas toucher mais faut quand même y
réfléchir c'est un droit ça je veux pas
revenir là-dessus mais faut quand même y
réfléchir c'est pas un choix individuel
ça engage tout le monde
donc voila quand même les choses sur
lesquelles il faut commencer à penser
s'ils voulaient il faut sortir de l'idée
que chacun fait ce qu'il veut oui chacun
fait ce qu'il veut c'est beau la liberté
j'aime la liberté on vous touche prend
par la main et bien visible
la liberté mais il faut comprendre que
c'est comme ne pas vacciner ses enfants
si vous voulez non seulement c'est grave
pour ses enfants mais c'est grave pour
les autres parce que la vaccination elle
n'a de sens que si presque tout le monde
est vaccinée parce que ceux qui n'ont
pas les moyens de se payer le vaccin ou
jeux qui ne sont pas protégés par le
vaccin risque de mourir si vous ne payez
pas vos propres enfants
c'est pas une décision individuelle
c'est pareil pour l'écologie quand vous
mangez de la viande c'est pas une
décision individuelle vous tuer un être
vivant sensible et vous participez
maxime allemand à la pollution
donc ça engage aussi les autres font
sentir sur la consommation de la viande
hachée vous évoquer cette idée de de
réduire la consommation de la viande est
ce qu'on peut expliquer pourquoi klm
quel impact ça pourrait avoir sur notre
pour moi c'est un peu une évidence parce
que je m'intéresse aussi depuis
longtemps en parallèle parce que c'est
un peu une question au 10 juin quoique
pas entièrement aux problèmes d'éthique
animal c'est monstrueux ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui vous savez quelle est la
part en biomasse des mammifères qui sont
libres c'est 5% peu près 5% des
mammifères sont libres aujourd'hui sur
terre le reste des mammifères et de la
viande en devenir
on a transformé la terre en enfer pour
les animaux on tue chaque année sont
milliards d'animaux dans des conditions
épouvantables dans les abattoirs et 1000
milliards de poisson salé dans sa
demeure un poisson lors de la remontée
des filets la vessie natatoire explose
les yeux vont arracher des orbites
l'estomac et le chauffage ressortent par
la bouche on n'a pas envie de l'entendre
mais c'est la vérité quand on mange du
poisson c'est ça qu'on fait est ce qu'on
peut vraiment se dire que tout ça c'est
normal tout va bien on a quand même
atteint un niveau de monstruosité
systémique qui me pose problème donc
renoncé à sa non seulement c'est
évidemment nous semble-t-il souhaitable
en termes d'éthique parce qu'on occasion
des souffrances infinies à des êtres
dont on sait qu'elles sont sensibles
c'est aussi signifiant en termes humains
indépendamment des animaux parce qu'on
pourra nourrir beaucoup plus d'hommes
directement avec les végétaux qu'avec
les végétaux ou l'utilisent pour nourrir
les animaux qui nourriront les hommes
donc évidemment pour endiguer la faim
dans le monde faut aller vers un mode
d'alimentation végétariens et puis à
l'échelle individuelle
aujourd'hui les chiffres de l oms sont
quand même assez clair le taux de
mortalité baisse avec une bonne
alimentation végétarienne
on a tout à gagner et je rappelle quand
même que l'industrie de la viande voulu
plus que salée des transports donc c'est
un impact drastiques mais quand j'ai
évoqué avec avec des amis la possibilité
à un grand chercheur grenoblois laurent
bègue a lancé l'initiative d'un d'un
jour sans viande par semaine mais ça a
été considérée comme impensable
on a reçu des tonnes invectives d'
insulte vous n'y pensez pas assez
dictatorial puis on voulait même pas
l'imposer en ville elle proposait un
jour sans viande est impensable
on n'y arrivera pas mais cette question
de marianne et le cas dans les
commentaires pour merci comme tous ceux
qui nous regardent actuellement et qu'on
salue qui nous dit une question pour
mathieu barrau que pouvons-nous faire
face à cette catastrophe nous citoyen
des pays appauvris dix pays du tiers
monde parce qu'on a des gens qui me
regardent du monde entier qu'on savait
également
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
répondre à magna inspiré moi je crois
que l'occident occident sens large a été
tellement n'est plus tellement
colonialiste aujourd'hui en termes
politiques mais est restée tellement
paternaliste à l'air vis-à-vis de tous
les autres pays
moi je crois que l'afrique par exemple
pas seulement évidemment mais je connais
un peu mieux l'afrique que l'asie par
exemple aujourd'hui devrait être une
source d'inspiration
vous avez d'autres sont au logis c'est à
dire d'autres constructions du réel vous
avez d'autres rapports à la nature vous
avez d'autres conception de ce qu'est
l'animalité de ce qu'est l'humanité de
ce qu'est la féminité moi je crois que
votre rôle
aujourd'hui
en fait c'est de nous apprendre ce qu'il
faut faire c'est de vous que nous avons
à apprendre parce que l'occident riche a
perdu son chemin
parlant du poids des lobbys aujourd'hui
on dénonce on voit régulièrement
c'est le quelques pins le cancer d'une
réussite possible c'est quoi pour vous
mais moi je connais pas bien ce milieu
donc j'ai pas grand chose à en dire mais
je pense qu'aujourd'hui vraiment ceux
qui s'adonnent à ce type de lobbying
pour que surtout rien ne change
l'avion pas peur des mots ça change
vraiment des criminels la plus
irrationnelle des postures actuelle
c'est le statut pour tenter de continuer
sur la voie que nous empruntons
aujourd'hui c'est littéralement
intenable c'est toute façon ça va pas
durer
qu'on le veuille ou non ça c'est certain
ça ne va pas durer mais ça peut
s'arrêter de différentes manières on
peut faire preuve d'un peu de dignité en
ayant compris qu'on est face à une
catastrophe majeure
il y aura quand même une catastrophe
majeure mais on peut la rendre d'abord
la mainmise et et puis profiter de cette
opportunité pour créer de nouveaux liens
un nouveau pacte avec le vivant des
réseaux d'entre elles faire quand même
quelque chose d'un peu de beau dans
cette situation critique
ce qui est vraiment ses vertus est ce
que surtout rien ne change pour se gaver
une dernière fois pour sucer comme ça
jusqu'à la moelle quoi l'os de la
croissance mortifère
je sais pas je les comprends pas en fait
et qu'est ce que vous pensez du du
greenwashing justement alors ça aussi
c'est compliqué parce que le
greenwashing en tant que tel c'est
condamnable
en même temps ça peut être le début
d'une prise de conscience le problème
c'est que c'est un peu tard il y à 40
ans on savait déjà tout ça si on voulait
savoir on le savait déjà il ya 40 ans ne
s'était pas mal de commencer un peu
faire évoluer les mentalités aujourd'hui
se dire on continue avec les mêmes
objets technologiques
on s'arrange pour que je sais pas le
papier soit un petit peu mieux recycler
ou qu'on peut lui un petit peu moins
gros visant le silicium de telle ou
telle façon
c'est ridicule on n'en est plus là donc
je le condamne pas stricto sensu parce
que si à la place du greenwashing ne
fait rien du tout c'est encore pire
donc autant quand même le mettre en
avant pour qu'il y ait une
conscientisation mais surtout pas pour
s'acheter à peu de prix une bonne
conscience écologique
ça c'est certain ça ne suffit pas et
cette question de alors qu'il passe très
vite le cirque ou de commentaires de
fred frédéric qui nous dit une question
monsieur barreaux que proposez vous pour
changer agir durablement sur les
comportements au niveau national au
niveau national on a quand même de la
chance en france il ya beaucoup de gens
pauvres mais on est quand même un des
pays les plus riches du monde hot
en moyenne donc premier problème
première action que je vois est très
sont évidentes redistribution il ne
s'agit pas j'en ai ras-le-bol pour me
caricature il ne s'agit pas d'instaurer
un communisme maoïste du jour au
lendemain dit même d'ailleurs à long
terme
personne ne veut ça tout le monde sait
que ça a été un échec mais enfin pour
moi déjà à l'existence d'un salaire
minimum est une évidence pour une
société élaboré c'est une évidence une
diminution du temps de travail est une
évidence enfin quand même le travail
c'est un moyen c'est pas un but n'est ce
pas on a quoi comme temps aujourd'hui
pour séné pour inventer pour créer
pourparlers pour disserter pour pour
faire ce qui fait que nous sommes des
vivants quoi est ce qu'on a vraiment
envie de travailler comme ça à la chaîne
la plupart des travaux sont pas
extrêmement épanouissant donc diminuer
le temps de travail que maintenant je
sais pas mais il faut que faut qu'on me
dit me voilà enfin
enfin comment contester que c'est un
progrès quand
aujourd'hui on aurait les moyens de
travailler très peu et de vivre de façon
décente
non on préfère travailler encore plus
pour gagner plus pour voir plus d'objets
technique pour boire plus voyager pour
pouvoir plus pollués pour pouvoir plus
s'imposer en terme de domination mais
cette figure de l'homme dieu prédateurs
non seulement elle est terriblement
lagarde
et en plus elle détruit tout sur son
passage les autres vivent et nous mêmes
les plantes les animaux ce qui fait la
beauté le change du monde mais je crois
aussi un salaire maximum moi parce que à
votre d'essence quand même faire un peu
de décence eux qu'il y ait des
inégalités c'est la vie c'est le monde
mais il y à un niveau d'inégalité qui
confine à l'obscène je sais très bien
que c'est dur à faire là on se dit ok
c'est un mytho piste mais si on le fait
les très riches ils vont partir oui bah
oui je sais bien
il faut que ce soit globale si nos
gouvernants ne sont pas capables de se
mettre autour de la table des
négociations et de tenter de faire en
sorte qu'on puisse survivre ils ne
servent à rien ce sont des polichinelles
je veux dire donc moi je pense que il
est quand même temps que les gens ont
prétendu mon sérieux est des
comportements sérieux s'ils ne peuvent
pas sauver la vie face la plus grande
catastrophe de notre histoire
mais pourquoi sont ils payés pourquoi
sont-ils élus enfin c'est leur rôle
c'est leur rôle
tout le monde sait ce qu'il faudrait
faire et on se dit ces gens qui sont
prétendument des élites qui sont
surdiplômés qui sont choisi pour la
plupart par leurs peuples ne sont pas
capables d'en parler parce que donc ça
va pas marcher
et pourquoi ça marcherait pas on sait ce
qu'il faut faire on est en danger
critique et nous représenter sont censés
être intelligent et rationnelle bas
qu'il le fasse sa part le rebond d'hier
justement ça fait deux ans maintenant et
quelques jours que emmanuel macron de la
tête de la france qu'elle
quel bilan vous faites un peu sur ses
deux premières années surplomb
écologique sur le
voilà sur la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique monsieur mac on
parle bien pas toujours d'ailleurs je
pense qu'en termes symboliques
il gagnerait peut-être pas aussi
incertaine ascétisme et puis à sortir un
peu comme ça de cette figure du
gestionnaire je pense qu'il faudrait
aller plus quand même vers une économie
de l'amour
plus qu'une gestion de la finance mais
au delà des mots il faut quand même des
actions on peut pas se contenter de
donner l'impression que les choses vont
bien ou qu'on a pris conscience des
choses au bout d'un moment il faut le
faire
vous savez qu on a encore vu les
émissions de co2 a augmenté à l'échelle
mondiale et à l'échelle locale c'est à
dire au niveau français l'année dernière
nous ne sommes pas dans la bonne
direction oui tendanciellement pour
quelques industries ça va plutôt mieux
oui il ya des efforts qui sont faits
monsieur macron c'est qu'il faut faire
des choses
je crois simplement qu'il n'a pas du
tout pris la mesure de l'amplitude de la
catastrophe nous ne sommes plus à des
mesures symboliques
nous ne sommes plus à infléchir
doucement le système pour que peut-être
dans cinq ans dans sa marche non non si
c'est pas radical sincère est effectif à
court terme les conséquences seront
désastreuses
mais en même temps je le comprends il
n'a pas été élu pour ça donc c'est aussi
notre folle ce n'est pas la sienne nous
élisons des représentants qui ne
s'engagent pas dans un programme
écologique révolutionnaire donc c'est
normal qu'ils ne le fassent pas après
tout les cohérent avec lui même
donc moi c'est pas à monsieur macro je
fais le reproche c'est à nous avant tout
les écolos font toujours des scores
minables aux élections peut-être qu'ils
sont mauvais d'ailleurs moi je les
connais pas personnellement je dis pas
faut voter pour tel ou telle formation
j'en sais rien a dire break mais enfin
j'imagine que quelqu'un et ça sera pas
moi qui se présenterait avec un
programme écologiste révolutionnaire
recueillerait quoi 0 25% des voix c'est
notre faute on ne le veut pas on ne l'a
pas c'est cohérent mais à ne pas le
vouloir on se suicide
ces problèmes de conscience de la
société c'est un problème de conscience
un problème d'inertie et c'est un
problème aussi là encore de symbole nous
n'avons pas compris de quel côté est le
sérieux
le rationnel et finalement le chance et
nous avons perdu le sens du monde pour
le dire comme mon ami le philosophe
jean-luc nancy alors au sein de ce
gouvernement il ya eu l'expérience de
nicolas hulot qui est quand même reconnu
pour avoir un discours comme assez
engagé finalement il est parti au bout
d'un an
qu'est ce que ça vous a amené comme
réflexion finale sur son expérience sur
son départ rapide certes emparé
d'impuissance politique
et oui mais je crois que nicolas hulot
était sincère et certains de ses
prédécesseurs le têt aussi et d'autres
dirigeants actuels sont sincères moi je
vais pas rentrer dans l'archétype du
tous pourris
il y as parmi nos dirigeants des gens
sincères mais ils n'y arrivent pas ils
n'y arrivent pas bien sûr il ya le poids
des lobbys bien sûr il ya l'inertie mais
comme on lisait et quelques instants il
n'y arrive pas parce qu'ils n'ont pas
été élu pour ça moi j'habite à grenoble
le maire de grenoble est dictée écolo je
le connais pas bien enfoncer vue de
trois fois je le connais un peu mais moi
je ne suis pas du tout affiliés à son
parti je vais pas faire partie de son
équipe municipale gergana gagner moi je
crois qu'il fait ce qu'il peut il
pourrait faire plus sans doute qui
pourrait faire mieux sans doute mais bon
il essaye un truc mais j'entends dans
les petits cafés du centre-ville où je
travaille le matin les commerçants
jouent scandalisé parce que le chiffre
d'affaires a baissé de 2 2%
parce qu'effectivement il ya un peu
moins de voitures en ville écoutez moi
je comprends que les commerçants ont des
loyers à payer des salaires à payer des
emprunts à rembourser je leur jette pas
la pierre
mais si on ne fait pas cet effort là on
est foutu donc c'est pas qu'un problème
de dirigeants on a aussi les dirigeants
qu'on mérite
faut quand même que nous on décide de
nos priorités est actuellement on ne
fait pas une priorité
c'est ça le problème c'est que si on
pouvait si on était tous d'accord le
peuple on pourra faire une révolution
pour faire triompher l'économie contre
nos méchants dirigeants et c'est même
pas le cas en ce moment on n'est pas
d'accord
le peuple et j'en fais partie nous ne
voulons pas en fait
aujourd'hui la révolution écologique
parce qu'elle irait contre notre confort
à court terme donc puisque personne ne
le veut je n'apparais lieu c'est normal
de par le bilan que vous faites
aujourd'hui
on replie de votre expérience s'il y
avait un message aujourd'hui adressé au
président de la république ce serait
lequel
moi je vais déjà dit une fois mais je
vous dise pas qu'ils écoutent il a autre
chose à faire je le comprends très bien
c'est que il est face à nos
responsabilités sans précédent donc soit
il a failli d'aller tous les autres pas
spécialement lui soit il est celui qui
aura été le dernier dinosaure d'un monde
à l'agonie et qui aura quand même une
responsabilité tragique par rapport au
futur parce que il savait plus que tous
ses prédécesseurs choix il est le
premier héros il est enfin celui qui
aura insufflé non pas le greenwashing
mais la révolution qui a une chance de
nous ménager un futur au moins en partie
vivable moi je crois quand même que
quand on est président de la république
la tentation d'être un super héros devra
être être grande
pourquoi veut-il rester dans l'histoire
pour avoir été un bon ou un mauvais on
verra gestionnaire ou pour avoir été
celui qui a gagné la guerre contre la
fin de la vie moi je crois que je me
laisserai tenter à sa place cette
question qu'on se pose parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de réactions les commentaires
et et c'est de se dire comment rendre
l'écologie populaire auprès de ceux qui
s'intéressent avant tout pouvoir d'achat
mais j'en sais rien j'en sais rien sa
part de l'éducation
oui mais l'éducation évidemment elle est
nécessaire et je suis content vous en
parliez parce que l'autre jour dans une
émission de télé on m'a dit bon quand
même
la bonne nouvelle c'est que les jeunes
eux ils vont prendre ça en main mais
c'est pas vrai du tout la plupart des
jeunes s'en foutent exactement comme
leurs parents et leurs grands-parents
il faut surtout pas se convainc que bon
on va s'en sortir grâce aux jeunes vous
savez nous les vieux enfin - les moyens
et puis les vieux ils ont été jeunes
avant les jeunes deviendront des vieux
cons comme tout le monde
donc il faut surtout pas croire que
cette génération va nous sauver il ya
une prise de conscience est certain il
ya une différence chez la plupart
comment sensibiliser je sais pas moi je
pense que
peut-être de temps en temps il faudrait
poser noces nos smartphones et puis
allez voir qu'une forêt c'est c'est
juste beau à en mourir quoi mais mais on
va pas on va pas prendre les gens de
forces sont mués en forêt toute façon ça
pourrit val et forêt donc c'est un
problème sans solution
vous évoquez le rapport aux médias ou
même d'un point de vue général des fois
ya certains mots que certains ont du mal
à entendre à se dire voilà on parle de
révolution de guerre décide parfois
d'aller on échange et même là dessus sur
le côté de voir toujours avoir un mot
positif mais finalement c'est pas
possible dans la barre en bon pour moi
le mot positif comme je vous le disais
c'est que tout est à réinventer ça c'est
quand même excitant parce que beaucoup
de générations étaient dans le suivisme
dans l'inertie ceux qui les précèdent et
gîtes allemands ont vécu sur les acquis
de papa maman nous si on fait ça on va
crever cette panne ou individuellement
peut-être pas tout le monde a bien sûr
soyons raisonnables mais
tendanciellement on va crever donc on a
la nécessité de tout réinventer ça moi
je trouve ça chouette quand même je
trouve ça excitant
je trouve ça enthousiasmant parce que
tout réinventer ces économies que c'est
politique c'est poétique c'est presque
sémantique faut réinventer un langage
faudra inventer un mythe aussi parce que
jamais rien de ces faits sans un système
du monde savait le mythe pour celui qui
le vit c'est le nom du monde en tant que
tel
donc on a tout à refaire ça c'est plutôt
chouette et on voit bien que même s'ils
avaient aucun problème écologique on a
quand même un gamin qui crèvent de faim
toutes les cinq secondes donc tout
n'irait pas bien donc il ya un problème
social on peut essayer le traiter en
même temps oui probablement on va vers
la catastrophe mais a quand même un
petit espoir
non pas qu'il aille bien et ça c'est pas
possible mais qu' on profite de cette
catastrophe pour régler aussi beaucoup
d'autres problèmes
ça serait pas mal il faut qu'on prenne à
bras le corps une question de cueillir
les commentaires qu'on remercie qui nous
dit croyez vous en la résilience de la
planète
peut-elle se régénérer ainsi que les
espèces si on lui si on diminue la
pression qu'on lui inflige aujourd'hui
alors oui donc même si on diminue pas
probablement si on diminue pas alors on
va aller au crash
et puis au bout d'un moment la
biodiversité c'est notre avenir
ça prendra quelques millions 10 millions
d'années bon mais moi je m'en fous de ça
ce qui m'intéresse c'est pas les espèces
et les gens les gens qui sont morts
morts on a trop souffrance seront morts
pour toujours moi si je vous dis oui bah
votre petite amie va mourir mais c'est
pas grave il ya un homme qui naît toutes
les secondes enfin j'en sais rien sur
terre vous en fichez parce que l'être
que vous aimez ou vous l'avez perdue
pour toujours
donc ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que c'est pas simplement un problème de
régénérer les espèces
oui à très très très très long terme
sans doute ça se fera et alors les
douleurs infligées aux routes étaient
telles que ça aura été une catastrophe
donc ça c'est ma première réponse la
deuxième réponse est que bien sûr si on
fait des efforts drastiques les impacts
seront bien moindres
et si on perd son 1000 espèces c'est la
même chose que si on en perd 2 millions
donc dans tous les cas il y aura des
dégâts mais l'amplitude des dégâts est
évidemment conditionnée à nos
comportements donc on est à un stade
faut pas dire tout est encore possible
ça c'est se mentir ça mais où on peut
quand même effectivement compter encore
sur une certaine forme de résilience
mais là vraiment vraiment vraiment ce
plancher là je palier là on est en train
de le passer et de le perdre
alors en même temps que cette interview
se déroule j'apprends une information
c'est qu'un pierre médevielle qui est
sénateur eu des s'apprête à rendre un
rapport d'information concernant l
herbicide de monsanto c'est une
information de nos confrères du parisien
et je cite rien ne prouve la
cancérogénicité du cliff aux as voilà
sur le glyphosate qu'est ce que vous en
pensez d'ailleurs ce voilà ce terme là
cette phrase cette citation alors
d'abord du boîtier épistémologique rien
ne prouve c'est complètement idiot parce
qu'on nous prouve jamais rien conscience
c'est à dire que oui rien ne prouve
jamais rien moi je vais vous prouver
quelque chose ce n'est qu'une question
de fiabilité et de
votre confiance donc rien ne prouve que
ces mortelles rien ne prouve que ce
n'est pas morte alors on va pas aller
loin comme ça
rien n'est jamais prouvé comme pour un
vaccin ce qui compte c'est la balance
bénéfice risque
vous n'aurez jamais la preuve qu'il est
totalement inoffensif et la preuve
qu'ils vous guéri à 100 pour fins qui
vous protège à 100% de la maladie donc
faut arrêter avec ce n'est pas prouvé
que cette phrase n'a aucun sens
scientifiquement au-delà de ça ça
c'était la remarque de philosophie des
sciences
c'est compliqué fenêtre parce que les
pesticides
c'est une calamité c'est probablement la
première cause de disparition des
espèces que nous évoquions tout à
l'heure avec la trophy des espaces de
vie donc lutter contre les pesticides
contre l'agriculture qui dévastent les
sols et accompagner la reconversion des
agriculteurs parce que faut pas que
j'aurais eu qui porte les frais il faut
le faire le cas particulier du livre
hosatte moi je me prononce pas parce que
en effet faut pas non plus dire
n'importe quoi et il y a quand même des
éléments d'analysé qui peuvent laisser
entendre que ce produit là en
particulier n'est effectivement
peut-être pas qu'on série jeunes il n'en
demeure pas moins qu'il peut quand même
avoir un impact réduit aux diversités et
il n'en demeure pas moins que beaucoup
d'autres sont très dangereux là je pense
qu'il faut raison garder moi je ne suis
pas spécialiste de ce dossier et on a
même cette cette phrase aussi qui nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans un climat
d'hystérie collective passé faudrait que
l'on supprime tous les pesticides et oui
c'est vrai qu'un climat d'hystérie
collective mais dans les deux sens dans
tous les sens le débat est devenu
hystérique faut sortir de ça un peu de
bienveillance un peu de bienveillance ou
arrêter avec cette condescendance et de
suffisance qui fait que certains pensent
tout savoir sur tout certains pesticides
ont permis d'endiguer la famine en
permettant certaines cultures dans
certaines zones du globe
c'est pas les pesticides intrinsèquement
qui sont condamnables
c'est la monstruosité à laquelle nous
sommes arrivés aujourd'hui
sans raison garder et sans remise en
cause et sans envisager le fait que le
monde nous avons construit n'est pas le
seul monde possible
ça c'est la pire violence qu'on puisse
faire à la pensée vos président de la
république
imaginons alors je sais que vous m'aviez
depuis tout à l'heure je veux pas
m'engager en politique c'est magie non
voilà vous êtes vous êtes au pouvoir
vous allez manette avec tout ce que le
constat que vous faites aujourd'hui s'il
y avait et on va dire 3 voire peut-être
cinq mesures si on peut aller jusque là
à prendre immédiatement voilà
aujourd'hui on est là vous allez pouvoir
il faut y aller tout de suite
vous savez si moi j'étais président
c'est que les choses iraient bien parce
que ça voudrait dire qu'on a donné la
parole à quelqu'un qui a
fondamentalement un discours qui est
inaudible
donc ça n'arrivera pas faut un président
je démissionnerai et j'écris de la
poésie mois l'écouté
c'est très difficile de se mettre à la
place de l'autre la critique est aisée
mais ce qui est fondamental fondamentale
et c'est peut-être ça la seule chose que
je répondrai à votre question c'est
d'aller vers l'expérimentation d'un
ailleurs prenons l'exemple des add je
prends pas la cas particulier notre dame
des landes je le connais pas bien donc
je vais en général je connais pas
c'est une habitude de rigueur
scientifique mais d'une façon générale
c'est très intéressant ce que font ces
gens ils expérimentent un autre rapport
au monde
quand on leur dit vrai vous défendez la
forêt il répond non nous sommes la forêt
qui se défend ses travaux comme phrase
alors peut-être qu'il ya des imposteurs
dedans j'en sais rien je n'étais pas là
mais en tout cas à titre
d'expérimentation
c'est nécessaire s'il était aux
commandes ce que je tenterai c'est par
tous les moyens possible d'explorer
d'autres chemins de sortir de cette
autoroute qui nous mène à l'impasse et
sur lesquels on accélère je n'ai pas de
solution clé en main parce que c'est un
problème difficile
la seule chose qui est sûre c'est que ne
rien faire rester dans le statu quo je
veux dire surtout surtout qu'on dit lyon
à vendre plus de voitures chaque année
mais comme on a quand même bonne
conscience moi c'est devant des voitures
hybrides plutôt que des voitures
thermiques
c'est ridicule on peut pas s'en sortir
comme ça eh bien oui mais alors ça veut
dire que j'employais de renault ou
peugeot vont perdre leur emploi
oui peut-être et bah donc du coup faut
les aider et donc du coup il faut
évidemment que soient pris en charge
collectivement et donc du coup il faut
partager c'est un problème systémique
il faut envisager des solutions
drastiques mais drastique pas au sens
d'une révolution bolchevique et encore
moins bien sûr d'une révolution fasciste
au sens en fait simplement de ce que une
situation pratique demande des mesures
qui n'ont pas encore été imaginées et
c'est ça qui manque aujourd'hui aux
politiques c'est le courage d'envisager
un ailleurs radical vous pensez vous un
discours il est inaudible aujourd'hui je
sais pas je ne sais pas en tout cas mais
voilà il ya un instant voilà à déporter
gt mais ça n'arrivera assez fatigué et
puis il faut laisser la parole à
d'autres voilà je l'aï déjà dit
plusieurs fois et donc là je vais
vraiment le tenir parce que il y a des
vrais experts je ne suis pas il ya des
écologues il y à des spécialistes des
glaciers et spécialiste de biologie
je voudrais vraiment avoir simplement
servi de passeur pour qu'on commence
enfin les égoutter parce qu'ils sont
désespérés ils vont c'est que lorsqu'il
devrait annoncer ce qu'ils savent
forcément les choses avaient changé sa
vie un peu comme quand on découvre un
crime de guerre
on se dit bon je vais le faire savoir au
reste du monde et forcément ça va pas
être toléré et là on découvre un
génocide nous exactement un écocide
c'est à dire que la vie sur terre est en
train d'être tués
rien ne se passe le sentiment qui est le
vôtre aujourd'hui celle qu'elle cite le
rapport à toute cette situation
alors moi je ne les avais pas tomber
dans l'optimisme qui est devenu un
mantra comme dit comme digg en cire
c'est à dire où dès qu'on s'exprime faut
dire bon j'y crois ça va aller non je
n'y crois pas ça ne va parler faut être
très clair mais en moins mon pari mon
choix et mon petit zeste d'espoir c'est
que face à cette situation critique on
fasse preuve d'un peu de dignité c'est à
dire que plutôt que de ne pas de mourir
moi je vois là on va pas touche mourir
je ne suis pas du tout dans ce
catastrophisme ridicule mais face quand
même à les catastrophes à venir
vous savez que dans quelques années les
plus gros mammifères sur terre ce sera
des vaches
c'est un peu triste quand même vous
savez que les requins qui existe depuis
des dizaines de millions d'années
aujourd'hui sont en train de disparaître
même lire aucun cas les sources est
cerné même les requins donc ce qui se
passe quand même est fondamentalement
triste et face à ce désespoir
moi ce que j'espère c'est que ça va
quand même créer de nouveaux liens et
que plutôt que de s'entretuer bas ou
choisira de partager un peu d'amour quoi
c'est la peur de la disparition de
l'humanité un court terme moyen terme
concrètement mais l'humanité c'est une
espèce parmi 7 millions bon moi je fais
partie de cette espèce je suis un peu
attaché évidemment donc bien sûr on est
un peu attachés à nos semblables parce
que c'est avec eux qu'on a des relations
d'amour de haine de connivence mais
c'est plus que ça le problème
combien même lima l'humanité irait bien
on ne peut pas détruire toute la vie sur
terre
ces milliards de milliards de vivant non
humains qui meurent savons pas rien
quand même c'est pas simplement de vos
ressources
ce sont des êtres vivants ils sont ce
monde et en plus vous avez raison
l'humanité est menacée
moi je crois pas que l'humanité va
disparaître en termes rationnels j'en
sais rien mon analyse personnelle c'est
l'humanité va pas disparaître mais
franchement d'avoir un petit nombre
d'heureux élus super riches qui vit dans
un entrepôt scène dévastée est ce que
c'est ça qu'on veut c'est de se dire que
nos enfants ne verront pas le monde dans
lequel on vit actuellement à ça c'est
sûr ça c'est pas un baril êtes une
vérité yam également nos enfants mais
même nous la plupart des animaux
extraordinaires qu'on voit aujourd'hui
je pense qu'on ne les verra plus quand
on sera vieux ça c'est en train de se
fermer mais mille espèces banal
est ce qu'on pourrait dire après tout
c'est plus dur ce colère on s'en fout
d'abord je crois pas ça mais on peut le
dire mais on voit que les hérissons sont
en train de disparaître et lapins de
garenne sont en train de disparaître
c'est à dire que les oiseaux en train de
disparaître les insectes sans contrainte
m et ça c'est une catastrophe globale
donc bon voilà c'est en train d'avoir
lieu et je veux pas finir sur un sourire
moi je garde quand même le secret espoir
qu'on saura inventé de l'amour qu'on
saura faire face avec un peu de dignité
à la catastrophe que nous avons nous
même causer et je vais peut-être en
rester là si vous l'avez bien parce
qu'il va falloir que j'y aille h22
tropini pour avant de conclure et là il
se dira ou pas être beaucoup de la
psychologie humaine dans ce monde
aujourd'hui c'est c'est important
aujourd'hui que la psychologie elle
change l on change le réflexe nos
comportements notre vision nos égos de
vouloir voir ceci plutôt qu'autre chose
la dernière voiture plutôt qu'une
ancienne moi si je veux faire du bien à
ma carrière de chercheur en
astrophysique j'ai intérêt effectivement
d'aller à toutes les invitations que
leur choix pour des conférences à
l'autre bout du monde là je le fais plus
je me pose pas en donneur de leçons
soient claires une fois de plus je ne
suis pas exemplaire a beaucoup beaucoup
de niveaux mais voilà c'est un exemple
parmi mille autres
je crois qu'il faut arrêter avec ça il
faut le dire et il faut le faire pour
conclure peut-être un message à tous
ceux qui nous regardent beaucoup de
jeunes qui sont là qu'ils y vont qu'est
ce que je peux retenir comme les salles
aujourd'hui
écoutez je crois qu'en reprenant la
phrase de bernard stiegler un bon
philosophe nicolas hulot disait soyez
disruptif la disruption c'est un beau
concept je le suis là dessus moi je vais
le dire un peu différemment je vais dire
là on est sur une courbe qui est
mortifère ce que gilles deleuze à notre
philosophe appelait une limite de mort
on est sur une ligne de mort et moi je
pense que ce qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre
c'est pas une discontinuité parce qu'on
peut pas repartir à zéro et on veut pas
repartir à zéro
l'humanité a créé de très belles choses
l'humanité s'est sorti d'un certain
nombre de problématiques de famine pas
partout hélas mais à certains endroits
de maladies avec brio et puis et puis
voilà on est quand même l'espèce qui a
donné bac léonard de vinci einstein
c'est pas mal quand même tout ça donc
moi je prône pas la discontinuité
radicale mais je prône un sorte de
changements de pente tellement abrupte
que nous ne l'avions pas même encore
envisagée donc ce que je dirai aux
jeunes et aux moins jeunes d'ailleurs
c'est le pire c'est la continuité de la
voie dans laquelle nous nous trouvons
essayons d ailleurs moi je ne suis pas
génial donc je n'ai pas trouvé lier qui
fonctionne mais j'ai l'espoir que de
jeunes génies trouve effectivement un
rapport au monde qui ne solutionnera pas
tout ça c'est impossible mais qui ne
laissera une chance voulais vous
remercier sincèrement aurélien barrau ça
faisait plusieurs mois que vous
souhaitez vous avant l'interview les
jets étaient rejugés entendons non mais
je suis ravi qu'on est con et plus vous
à voir aujourd'hui parce que je
considère que c'est l'une des revues qui
est passionnante sur un sujet qui est
majeure et est important et en tant que
joueur c'est toujours intéressant
d'avoir un éclairage profond avec voilà
un constat prendre un peu de hauteur se
ressource sont tous ces enjeux dont on
parle beaucoup actuellement et parfois
en surface là on a pu faire donc je suis
très content rien dit parce que c'est
aussi pour tous ceux qui n'ont rien et
en tant que journaliste c'est toujours
ce qu'on recherche c'est d'avoir
justement des témoignages qui puisse
mettre en perspective et expliquer les
choses et je pense que cette heure
d'interview a permis de le faire je vais
montrer et je me montre moi même à
l'écran c'est le livre qui est sorti
voilà tout simplement de commencer comme
ça comme ça vous vous levez vous verrez
bien il est juste là voilà c'est le
livre de renaud barrault donc le plus
grand défi de l'histoire de l'humanité
qui est sorti donc c'est que je veux
dire que je remarque aussi écrit un
autre livre qui salue de plusieurs
recommandations pour moi c'est la suite
du bien en fait je trouve qu'il ya plus
loin je le recommande aussi et puis à
pablo serving et ses amis qu'on ait créé
une autre fin du monde est possible ça
poursuit en fait la petite réflexion que
j'ai fait et je les recommande également
l'ensemble de cette interview à
retrouver tout de suite sur cela que le
lien de cette vidéo pour encore le
commenter le partager dans quelques
instants
on mettra aussi la vidéo sur la chaîne
youtube de brut l'application brut
haussier à télécharger et puis pour tous
ceux qui souhaiteraient aussi vous
la continuité c'est que c'est pour ça
aussi vous devez nous laisser c'est qu'à
20 heures vous serez sur le plateau de
sur france 5 de ses politiques avec
karim rissouli pour la deuxième partie
donc de ces politiques
donc à partir de vieux vins j'arrête
voilà maintenant je veux retourner à mes
recherches écrire de la poésie vous
pouvez faire discret médiatiquement que
c'est aussi parce que c'est que
certaines personnes se disaient après
owen un moment ça devient est plutôt
tant que tel quoi la parole publique et
je suis fatiguée et puis j'ai goûté à
quelques effets pervers de ces choses là
donc voilà laissons la parole à notre
merci beaucoup au revoir et merci à tous